in this lesson you're going to learn how
to graph polynomials using n behavior
zeros and multiplicities we're going to
go through three examples so you can
understand how to work with this concept
the first one we have y equals 2 times X
minus 2 X plus 3 X minus 4 now this
one's already in a factored form and the
first thing you want to do is you want
to find the zeros and to find the zeros
what you do is you take each of these
groups each of these factors and you set
them equal to 0 now if it's not factored
if you can go ahead and try and factor
it and we'll do that in the next example
so here you just make like a mini
equation X minus 2 equals 0 X plus 3
equals 0 and X minus 4 equals 0 and when
you solve these you can see you're
getting x equals 2 which means it's
going to cross the x axis right here at
2 over here when you subtract 3 from
both sides you get x equals negative 3
so it's crossing here and then when you
solve this last one x equals 4 that
gives us another x intercept or what's
referred to as a 0 now they call it a 0
because the y-coordinate is 0 basically
when you put in x equals 4 it's going to
make all this 0 that's why the Y value
is 0 we call it a 0 now the next thing
you want to look at is does the graph go
up to the right or down to the right
does it go up to the left or down to
left that's what it's referred to as the
end behavior meaning what happens at the
ends of the graph the left hand and the
right end and the way that you determine
that is by this leading coefficient now
the leading coefficient if it's positive
that means it's going to go up towards
positive infinity so I'm just going to
draw an arrow going up to the right if
this was a negative it's gonna be going
down towards negative infinity now if
you're not sure you just want to test it
out you could put in a number say for
example like 10 so I mean you're going
way over here to the right if you put 10
in you're gonna see that you're gonna
get a large positive number that tells
you it's going up but this is what's
referred to as the leading coefficient
test okay or end behavior now the next
thing you want to analyze is is a graph
going up to the left or down to the left
and the way you do that is you want to
look at the
of the polynomial what I mean by that is
if you were to multiply this out you
don't have to multiply it out you can
see it's x times x times X which gives
you X cubed and when it's an odd degree
the end behavior left and right is going
to be opposite meaning if this goes up
this goes down if this were to go down
to the right and then I would go up to
the left and the way you can remember
that also is if you're familiar with the
graph y equals x cubed see how it's
going up to the right and down to the
left over here if this was like a
negative X cubed it would go down to the
right see that leading coefficients
negative one but because it's an odd
degree it's going to opposite direction
up to the left now when you have an even
degree okay
even like for example x squared or X to
the fourth what do those graphs look
like they look like parabola either
going to be both going up or if I do
let's say I did a negative then you can
see they're both going down so with this
even degree it's going to have the same
and behavior meaning both up or both
down I just remember opposite oh for odd
over opposite easy to remember that way
now the third thing we want to pay
attention to is the multiplicities
multiplicities means like multiples like
duplicates triplicates like that but you
can see here we these did not occur more
than one so we just had 1 4 1 negative 3
1 2 when they occur just once like that
at these zeros at these x-intercepts
it's gonna look like a line okay I mean
it's gonna go straight through what
happens Mario if it it occurs twice well
if it occurs twice like it's a duplicate
or a multiplicity of 2 let's say for
example at this point this will look
let's say this was 2 and it was a
occurred twice like when you factor it
you set the fashion to zero then what it
has is it has a parabola shape at that
point it's gonna essentially bounce off
that point if it was coming from this
direction it would bounce like that what
happens if it's a multiplicity of 3 well
then it's gonna look like X cubed it's
gonna have this X cube shape almost like
it's gonna bounce and go the other
direction then it bends like that so it
looks like the graph y equals x cubed
what have
this X to the fourth well remember if
it's even this is an easy way to
remember if it's even it's going to
bounce okay or look like this parabola
shape either like this or like this if
it's on like one three five seven
it's going to have this shape or goes
through okay
and if you want to get fancy like when
it's like X cubed or X to the fifth it's
gonna have that X cubed shape or X to
the fifth sheet as it as it passes
through that point but just remember odd
it goes through even it doesn't it
bounces so now the only other thing that
you might be asking is you say well how
did you know like not to go way up here
and then way down here and then like
that we're gonna learn about that in
calculus you're gonna learn about what
you call the extreme values like maximum
is in the minimums these turning points
or these bends but if you want to be
more precise you could pick some points
in between these x-intercepts these
zeroes you could put like three in and
see what you get for the y-value or you
could put like you know negative 1 or
negative 2 in and see what you get for
the y-value and get a better sketch but
this is just a pretty good sketch one
key point that you might want to do is
find the y-intercept that's easy to find
you're just putting 0 in for X so let's
go ahead and do that on this one that
would give us negative 2 3 and negative
4 so that comes out to negative 6 times
negative 4 is 24 times 2 is 48 so I
really should have gone up higher but
this point here is gonna be the point 0
comma 48 and you have a pretty good
sketch now let's go into some other
examples to show you more about how to
work with it okay number two we've got y
equals negative x cubed plus three x
squared how do we get a good graph of
that using zeros and end behavior and
multiplicities well the first thing you
want to do if you can is you want to
factor this so what I notice is is that
I can factor out x squared and because
it starts with a negative I'm going to
factor out a negative x squared so
that's gonna leave us with X minus 3 now
you can check your work if you
distribute the negative x squared back
in we get back to the original
polynomial the other thing you want to
pay attention to when you're doing this
is you want to make sure you write your
polynomial in D
sending order so from the highest power
all the way down to the lowest power
that's what standard form is or
descending order now we have it factored
we want to set these groups or these
factors equal to zero so let's make some
equations here negative x squared equals
0 and X minus 3 equals 0 if we multiply
both sides by negative 1 that gives us x
squared equals 0 if we take the square
root ok we're just getting 0 but you see
how this is x squared that's like x
times X we're really getting x equals 0
twice okay so I'm going to write this
multiplicity of 2 meaning it occurs
twice this one when I add 3 to both
sides I get x equals 3 this is only
occurring once so see notice this is x
squared if I had like a 3 here like X
minus 3 cubed then I would have 3 3
times that would be like a multiplicity
of 3 but this only occurs once here so
now what we're gonna do is were going to
plot that on our x-axis these are our
zeros or x-intercepts we've got 0 & 3
let's go to end behavior now so do you
think the graph is going to go up to the
right or down to the right what do you
think well if you said down to the right
you're absolutely right because it has
that leading coefficient which is
negative and then what about for the
left-hand behavior is it going up or
down well the degree okay when we talk
about degree that's the highest power
here which is 3 that's odd
remember odd is opposite so we're going
up to the left if it's even degree like
if this is X to the 4th then these would
be the same either both down or both up
so now we have to look at the
multiplicities we said that zero occurs
twice so here at x equals zero
it's good because it occurs twice it's
going to look like a parabola like x
squared okay so it's going to have this
kind of a shape over here actually goes
three this only has a multiplicity of
one it just occurs once that means this
is going to just go straight through
like a line okay so the only thing is
you know you might be saying how do they
not go all the way up here right or how
come I didn't just go like that and
again this is just a rough sketch you
could plot some more points in between
you know these X intercepts okay these
zeros and get an idea
you know that would be good but for this
video for right now we're just talking
about a basic sketch using those three
components okay number three this one's
got a little bit of everything in it so
it's a really good example but before I
dive into that one if you're new to the
channel and we're meeting for the first
time my name is Mario of Mario's math
tutoring and I tutor students every day
full-time and basically what I try to do
is take what I learn about what helps
students the easiest the quickest the
best in my tutoring sessions and I bring
it to these videos so that you can
benefit from my tutoring as well so the
channel is all about making learning
math less stressful so you can raise
your grade pass your class and go on to
pursue your dreams so if this is
something you're interested in check out
more math videos on my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring and let's dive
into this last example now the first
thing we want to do this one's all
nicely factored for us right so let's
look at the zeros if we set the factors
equal to zero you can see we're gonna
get X plus one equals zero which it
gives us negative one X minus three
equals zero which is gonna give us three
and then here we set this one to zero
we're going to get negative two but
notice how this one has a multiplicity
of two so I'm just gonna put
multiplicity of two something like that
and this one has a multiplicity of three
so I'm just gonna say multiplicity three
something like that just to kind of
remind us when we go to graph it so here
you can see with the x-intercepts
negative one positive three and negative
two okay now how about end behavior it's
a graph going to go up to the right or
down to the right leading coefficients
positive so we know that's going to go
up to the right now what about the
degree now the degree you don't want to
foil all this out I mean you could but
it would take you a while we can just
look at these exponents this is X to the
first X to the second X to the third
when we multiply what do we do to the
exponents we add them 3 plus 2 is 5 plus
1 is 6 so that means that this is a
sixth degree which is even and when it's
even the end behavior to the right and
the left is going to be the same either
both up or both down okay if it's odd
opposite right now we get to the fun
part the shape of the graph so here at
negative 2 that has a multiplicity of 3
so what that means is when this
raph approaches negative - it's gonna
have that cubic shape okay if you want
you can draw it straight through but if
you want to be a little bit give it a
little bit better sketch it's gonna have
that live close execution at negative
one
okay this had a multiplicity of 1 which
means it's going to go through this
point like a line kind of just like
straight through like that it's not
going to bounce off it's not going to
have that cubic shapes gonna be like a
line and then the last one at 3 that has
a multiplicity of 2 which means that
this is going to have that ax squared
shape like that parabola shape at this
point again the only thing that's
missing are picking some points maybe in
between some of these zeros to get an
idea about you know how high up it goes
or how low it goes but this is a pretty
good sketch of our graph the things that
we didn't cover in this video were de
cartes rule of signs the rational root
theorem or rational zero theorem for
finding these zeros if you can't easily
factor it and I talk about those things
as well as the graphing it all together
with what we did here in that video
right there so follow me over to that
video right there where we dive into
even more depth on graphing polynomials
I'll see you in that lesson